[Applause]
across the island a sudden groundswell
of opposition to the rajapaksa family
and what's widely seen as a man-made
crisis
protesters defied a government curfew on
sunday prompting sri lanka's entire
cabinet to resign
all 26 members except for the president
gotta buy rajapaksa and his brother the
former president now prime minister
mahinda rajapaksa
[Applause]
after declaring a 36-hour curfew the
government cut off social media to try
and prevent these demonstrations
in a suburb of candy protesters
grievances were met with tear gas and
water cannon
university students professionals
mothers and children all came out
despite government orders
[Applause]
we would like to tell the government
that whatever happened today they can't
stop tens of thousands of people joining
the struggle it is a joke if the
government thinks it can stop this
people's protest by using barriers tear
gas or shooting
the economy is in tatters it's the worst
economic crisis in decades
people are angry at the skyrocketing
cost of living increasing shortage of
essential goods and rolling blackouts
the government is saddled with huge
debts and dwindling reserves that now
limit its ability to bring in basic
supplies
critics say mismanagement bad planning
and corruption has aggravated the
situation
we are stripped off of our basic rights
our right to fuel our right to
energy we don't have power for almost 16
hours a day now
there's no gas there's no petrol there
is nothing to eat there is no medicine
what can we do if this continues we will
have to jump into the sea
with frustrations boiling over and
protesters attempting to storm his home
president rajapaksa assumed emergency
powers and briefly blocked access to
whatsapp and other messaging services to
stem the protests
it backfired
opposition figures call the measures
illegal
sri lanka is not a dictatorship
this is a democracy and we will fight
for the rights of the people and we will
fight to protect democracy in our
motherland
what's more the protests appear to be
drawing people from across ethnic and
religious lines uniting to challenge the
status quo namely the ruling family in
charge
andrew chappelle al jazeera